what have you learned from bombing on
stage what does that do to you as a
person but that's what's beautiful about
comedy is it's it's real it's much like
sports where if you don't throw the ball
right it won't go in the basket it's the
same with comedy if it's not funny they
won't laugh and if it is funny they'll
laugh and there's something great about
that reality but also I'm such a nut job
and I have weird thoughts and maybe my
childhood I was outcasts a lot and a
weirdo and all this that I think stand
up you get to say your thoughts and if
you package them the right way it'll
make a room full of people happy and I
think that's what keeps me going and I
get to go how weird can I get how how
up can I get and have them stay
with me and then that's a thrilling
thing I you know we're all insecure in
our own way and when you bomb it
validates every sick twisted dark
thought you ever had you're boring no
one likes you you don't deserve love you
shouldn't be up here they're right
getting good at stand up is being able
to beat that and then you you win